hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q
a for kids and others
and we seem to have lots of questions
saved up or uh queued up here
let me see all right let's start off
with one from mikhail
the question was is there any experiment
in computation
similar to the miller urae experiment
uh in origins of life
well so first of all let me let me say a
little bit about the miller urae
experiment
which was in i think the early 1950s
so the question is how did life
originate
on earth life is has a lot of
complicated features it has dna
it has proteins it has lots of
complicated mechanisms
and so on question is how did all that
stuff originate
and how do you go from sort of inorganic
chemicals and i say inorganic in quotes
because
when you study chemistry there's this
field of so-called organic chemistry
which basically means chemistry of
bigger molecules that have carbon and
hydrogen and oxygen and things like that
in them as opposed to smaller molecules
with more exotic
kinds of elements in them it doesn't
mean organic you might mean
might think means relating to life but
there
the word organic just means with those
particular carbon
and so on related elements which are the
most common elements
that show up in life but
it isn't the case that all things with
carbon and hydrogen oxygen
have to do with life i mean something
like um
that there are plenty of of chemicals
whether it's carbon dioxide or whether
it's some
plastics that are still hydrocarbons
um and made from carbon hydrogen and so
on
and don't have anything directly to do
with life so i
uh but but one of the questions is how
do you go
from just a random collection of
chemicals to
something like a living system and
that's been
complicated to answer and there are
probably many steps
and one of the things that was done in
the 1950s was to ask the question
if you just pour random chemicals
together
and just sort of heat them up a bit and
stir them around
can you start getting more complicated
molecules
of the kind that one might see in in
living systems
you know one wouldn't expect a whole
giant dna molecule with
you know six billion base pairs like we
have to be sort of to come out of just
stirring things around for a few minutes
but you might expect some molecules that
have i don't know
uh 20 30 50 atoms in them
uh to be things that would somehow
spontaneously form
as a result of just chemical reactions
without
any kind of long story of biological
evolution or anything like that and
indeed that was exactly what was
discovered
you just throw all these all these
chemicals together
and uh some of them start combining and
uh you
you know you pretty soon you're getting
uh slightly larger molecules
that are slightly reminiscent of the
kinds of molecules that show up in
living systems
now uh there are many other places where
you get
these sort of slightly longer molecules
like for example in interstellar space
uh there are molecules that can be quite
big um that
are formed in very different ways the
molecules are formed
in chemical reactions on the earth so so
a lot of places where
uh a place where it's sort of easy to
have chemical reactions is in liquid in
the sort of liquid phase
of materials because it's a place where
the molecules are
are dense enough that they are often
hitting each other
but yet they're not so dense that
they're sort of all packed in
and forming a rigid array like in a
solid where two sort of different
molecules can't ever find each other so
the liquid phase is um uh
is the place where chemical reactions
are kind of uh at their best so to speak
and that's kind of why
you know in things like airport security
it's like worrying about
how much volume of liquid uh one might
have
is a significant thing because if you
want a chemical reaction that might
produce some uh explosion or some other
bad thing
um to happen it's probably going to be
something that is achieved
by by having by mixing liquid
chemicals together in the liquid phase
so
uh in any case in in on in the early
earth for example no doubt the chemical
reactions which eventually led to life
were liquid phase chemical reactions in
interstellar space
there aren't liquids um and but instead
they're very dilute
individual molecules and so the way that
larger molecules get formed then is
telespace is rather different
it's it's usually the sort of individual
collision of molecules with each other
not the kind of continual jostling
around that happens in a liquid
but nevertheless even in a stellar space
some slightly complicated molecules can
be formed
um and when when one's looking for
example
at the atmospheres of other planets
or even exoplanets planets around other
stars
sometimes you can get a little bit of
information about um uh
what might be in the in the well i don't
think we yet have that information but
it will be possible to get the
information about what kinds of
chemicals exist in the atmospheres of
exoplanets
um just by looking at light coming from
those exoplanets
possibly light that when the planet goes
in front of their star
maybe they'll be things absorbed as that
light goes through the atmosphere of the
planet and so on
things like that will potentially allow
one to get
information about what kinds of of
chemicals exist in the atmospheres of
those
planets so the question is what kinds of
are there molecules there where we say
aha that's a molecule that corresponds
to something to do with
with life and there was a recent thing
on venus actually
that in the clouds of venus there were
phosphines
that seemed like they were being
observed and people were like well
phosphines are kind of complicated
molecules and they're kind of a little
bit like molecules that
are building blocks for life and maybe
that's a sign that one
should be looking on venus for possible
uh life maybe in the clouds uh uh
you know above the above the surface of
venus but in any case that's
so kind of what happened um
uh in um the uh the miller ura
experiment was this kind of a liquid
phase thing where you're sort of
putting molecules together and getting
somewhat bigger molecules
okay so a question that might arise is
well
how do you go all the way to actually
get life as it has formed on earth
and it's not clear what the essential
feature of life is but for example self
reproduction
is an important feature and there are
all kinds of theories about
types of materials like clays for
example which are
solids but they have a lot of sort of
repeating a lot of
different elements that can exist in
them and maybe there are ways that they
could be have been used to sort of
templates
for creating molecules that would then
be repeated
sort of from generation to generation if
that was an important thing
in the origin of life um but we don't
know the details of how life originated
on
on earth um and uh but
but one thing that one does get
information from is
throw a bunch of chemicals together see
what you get now an interesting feature
is
most of the time when people are
thinking about making chemicals
they are not thinking about what is
sometimes in the business of chemistry
called one
pot synthesis you just sort of throw
everything in a pot
and uh and see what happens they're
rather thinking of
how do we very carefully do this
reaction that reaction that reaction
to end up with a particular product like
we're trying to make a particular
industrial chemical
or we're trying to make a particular
drug um
how do we arrange how do we go from the
kinds of
components that we can just sort of buy
off the shelf from a chemical supply
company
you know whether it's i don't know
ammonia or whether it's some
uh some um uh uh
some other chemical you know put water
in put this in
put things that are sort of readily
available uh chemicals that can be got
from uh just a chemical supply company
how do you go from the chemicals you can
buy from a chemical supply company
to manufacturing that uh amazingly
useful
you know drug of some kind and usually
what happens is
people invent this whole series of moves
that you can make it's like
okay pour these two chemicals together
and heat them up to this temperature
okay then for this amount of time then
okay then take that result
uh add this chemical heat it up in this
way do this
do that and so on and usually in the
chemical synthesis that are done today
there may be 20 or 30 steps that you go
through
of of trying to uh sort of add this heat
that do this etc
to end up with the particular product
you want
and and that kind of synthesis one of
the big issues is what is the yield of
that process
that is given the amount of material you
put in what fraction of the stuff that
comes out is actually the chemical you
want
and that yield is gradually tweakable
you can use catalysts for example
which are materials or chemicals which
are not directly going to contribute to
the end product
but they typically might even be solids
where they have a sort of a shape on
their surface where molecules that are
going to be relevant
to the reaction uh like collecting in
these little crevices for example in a
surface
and they end up collecting in those
crevices in such a way that
um they align themselves so they'll
react in a particular fashion or
something like that
um there's sort of a whole complicated
art of building catalysts
that have the right sort of surface
structure or the right chemical
properties and so
on to speed up reactions in biology
we have a class of catalysts called
enzymes
that are incredibly efficient at
speeding up uh biological reactions
without enzymes
biology really wouldn't work the way it
does they they speed things up by
by factors of billions and things like
this uh they're often very sensitive to
the temperature at which they operate
um which is why sort of life exists and
and we
tend to exist only at a pretty narrow
range of temperatures
the um so
it um uh i think
anyway so the the question here um of
uh how does one get the whole sort of
network that corresponds to
the chemistry of life we don't know the
answer um
we know that there are many kinds of
networks of chemicals that achieve
things like for example
uh metabolism is a particular network of
different kinds of chemicals being
involved
that all contribute to being able to uh
to you know take energy turn it in take
food turn it into energy
things like this there's some theories
about how
uh when you throw different chemicals
together there'll be sort of a tendency
to get
things like auto catalytic sets things
where there are sort of sequences of
chemicals
that sort of catalyze where one chemical
sort of automatically catalyzes
other reactions and where you get the
sort of pattern
of of chemicals affecting other
chemicals and so on
now that kind of segues into something
more computational because
it always used to be the case when i was
younger at least
that um uh you would see if you went
into sort of a biology lab or something
you'd see these giant wall charts and it
would they would have
titles like you know the metabolic
pathways of the cell
or various kinds of signaling pathways
and so on and they'd be full of
uh of little signs for different kinds
of chemicals and arrows saying
this chemical reacts with that one to
produce that to produce that and so on
i think those wall shots have gone out
of fashion um possibly because
what's now known about how biology works
is so complicated
it wouldn't really fit on a very good
wall chart but
um the the idea of this kind of whole
network of reactions
is one that does seem to be
characteristic of biology and there's
sort of a question of can you capture
the essence of that kind of network of
reactions uh in a completely different
way than
than life on earth does it can you make
something where
you know the essence of what's going on
is this network that has these various
loops and various transitions and things
like this
and do it with completely different
chemicals and is that the essence of
what life is doing
we don't know for sure i think that um
things that i've actually looked at even
fairly recently
have been along the lines of thinking
about
how you make sort of uh idealized
chemistry
that has um that sort of captures these
computational aspects of chemical a
affects b affects c effects a affects d
effects whatever
where the abcde doesn't really matter
what they are
what matters is just something is
affecting something that's affecting
something
so one of the things i've actually
looked at quite a bit recently
is um the question of
instead of emphasizing doing chemical
synthesis where you have one product
as the output think about the
possibility
that you can have something where
there's a whole network of possible
chemical reactions you know producing
all these different things
and you're using all these different
things and you're eventually building up
this kind of giant
uh graph giant network of all these
different reactions
rather than the thing where you're
trying to synthesize one particular
thing and i suspect that life
is much more the use all these reactions
and have them all flow in different ways
rather than be produced one thing when
we think about
doing things with computers for example
uh we tend to think it tends to be a lot
easier for us to think about
do this then do this then do this or
maybe if we're thinking about things in
terms of functional programming
apply this function then this function
then this function apply that function
to this structure
et cetera et cetera et cetera the idea
that there are many things happening in
parallel
that are also independently happening
and then they'll be sort of
somehow as things go on there'll be more
independent things happening but
eventually
every so often uh one will get the thing
one wants
that way of thinking about how things
work computationally
is one that we're much less able to do
it happens to be
from what we know now from our sort of
project in fundamental physics
it happens to be that the universe works
that way if you look at the different
parts of space
sort of space is in our models
consists of these sort of independent
atoms of space these indus
independent discrete points maybe 10 to
the 400 of them in our universe
um huge number of them in our universe
and um uh the the way that sort of the
universe
progresses through time is by
these various atoms of space are each
connected to other atoms of space
and that whole pattern of connectivity
is getting continuously updated
space is kind of getting continuously
refreshed
every point in space is getting
continuously refreshed
and um but that's happening all in
parallel all these different points in
space are all doing that in parallel
um it's not something where you can say
let's look at this thing then this thing
then
this thing and so on um so
but there's kind of a big thing in our
models of physics there's a
property of causal invariance that means
that
even though all these things are
happening independently and in parallel
and it's all very complicated
it's possible if you look at the right
feature of the system
to see simple things that happen in the
system even though a lot of what happens
in the system is extremely complicated
there's sort of a slice of what's
happening that's very simple
and it turns out one of the big things
from our physics project is
this one of the slices that comes out is
relativity
einstein's theory of relativity is sort
of a slice of what you can
make sense of in the in the sort of
evolution of the structure of space
much of what happens in the evolution of
structure of space you can't make sense
of it's
it's computationally irreducible and so
on but some of it you can
what i've actually realized recently is
that a lot of the story of what
consciousness
is and how sort of consciousness differs
from sort of all the stuff that exists
in the universe
is the fact that consciousness is a
story of sort of having a single thread
of experience we don't have sort of
this experience as if we're all these
separate atoms of space
we have a kind of coherent thread of
experience so this happens then this
happens then this happens and so on
and it's not obvious that we can form a
consistent view
of what's happening in the world in
terms of this happens then this happens
then this
happens and it's a feature of this thing
called causal invariance that means that
with even though all these different
places in space
are getting updated separately it's
still possible
for us as the sort of consciousness that
has a sort of single
thread of perception of what's going on
in the universe
to form a view of that that is
consistent both self-consistent
for ourselves and consistent kind of one
person one consciousness
to another and that that's kind of a um
a way of understanding sort of the
difference between what happens just
sort of
in nature all these sort of things
happening in parallel
and our perception of it our sort of
consciousness
uh version of what's going on which is
much more the sort of sequentialized
version of what's happening
and that means that that that's sort of
the the fundamental reason why when we
think about
doing programming for example where many
things are happening in parallel
but that's fundamentally quite difficult
for us to understand
because the whole story of our kind of
you know consciousness and our
experience and so on
is all based on this sort of one
one experience going through time so to
speak rather than this sort of whole
parallel collection of different
experiences so when it comes to thinking
about something like chemistry or
biology for that matter
we have a great tendency to try to
reduce it to the one
thing happening through time and so you
know if you look at a medical textbook
for example
you'll see all these charts that say
this happens then this happens then this
happens this effect that affects that
they're very sequentialized so to speak
the
true story of biology is likely not like
that
it's likely something which has many
different things happening kind of in
parallel
and it likely it's sort of building up
this graph
of of interactions that somehow achieves
the purposes it needs to achieve
um but it does you know it in a way that
is actually fairly hard for us to
understand
and i think we kind of need a bit of a
new paradigm for thinking about things
about sort of the this distributed
parallel computation
and that if we have that paradigm we may
start to understand a whole bunch more
about how biology actually works
and if we're interested in things like
the origin of life it's important to
understand what is the essence
of how life on earth actually works i
think that what happens
what we're about to see is kind of a
fairly exciting way of importing things
that we've learnt
from the last hundred years or so
physics a lot of powerful things have
happened in physics in the last 100
years
to import a bunch of those ideas into
biology basically to understand more
about the sort of very parallel kinds of
things
that are happening in the space of
chemicals instead of the space of
physical space
of all these atoms of space the space of
possible chemical species
the space of possible different chemical
compounds and how they react
so it's something i've been actually
currently curious about
now you can ask the question the um
of whether uh whether these kinds of
processes that lead to sort of a
lifelike thing
being produced first question is what is
a lifelike thing
and this has been sort of a mis
mysterious story
for the last few thousand years of you
know what
is life really is there some you know
magic
spark that makes something alive versus
not alive
and people have these various
definitions you know the one in
antiquity was
if it moves itself then it's alive that
was a common one
and you know eventually one had steam
engines and things like that and that
wasn't a viable definition
uh there were definitions like it has
certain kinds of chemicals in it
but then we learned how to synthesize
those chemicals so that wasn't a
definition either
maybe it has certain properties with
respect to entropy and thermodynamics
and so on
but we could synthesize things that we
could create systems
that had those properties as well or
another one that was quite big
is uh it uh it has self-reproduction
it makes copies of itself and uh but of
course you know
people will say well at some level you
know fire when it spreads instead of
making a copy of itself
but more more explicitly when you have
malware on computers it's very common
for computer worms computer viruses
to make copies of themselves albeit in a
sort of virtual world
so that's not a a sort of unique
definition about life and what we
realize in the end is that
life as we know it on earth it's very
easy to define
because all life on earth is has uh
extremely similar sort of chemical
processes going on it's it's got rna
most of it has dna it has proteins it
has
uh you know cell walls that work in the
same way
it has you know a tremendous amount of
detail that's the same
presumably because it's derived from the
same essentially common ancestor
in the history of life on earth and so
life on earth is very easy to recognize
life in the abstract is not clear what
it means i have long believed that life
in the abstract
is really just a story of sophisticated
computation that as soon as
you're doing something that is
complicated it is
life in the abstract so to speak um it
is not life in the specific of life on
earth
with dna and so on but it is life it is
it is perfectly lifelike so to speak in
the abstract
and you know it's a challenge when
spacecraft go to mars for example
it's always a challenge of how do you
tell if there's life there
and i remember when i was a kid and the
first mars landers
were were landing there there were a
whole collection of experiments about
uh you know could you tell if the
martian soil was
alive and obviously the most very basic
experiment
uh which wasn't known until they were
landers is you go there
and you just look around with a camera
and do you see a field of grass or do
you see a little creature coming up to
you and
and uh and smiling at the camera or
something
um and obviously that wasn't what was
seen and then
then there's a question well are there
microorganisms in the soil and things
like that
uh and that um uh that that's
less clear um and in fact in the
experiments that were done in the
in the 1970s i guess early 1970s
um the uh one of the sort of the top
experiments was you
feed the soil sugar and you see whether
it metabolizes
because that's what life on earth would
do but
that probably isn't a very abstract
definition of life
because you know it wouldn't take much
of a of a sort of a a
shift in how life works to end up with
something where you feed it
sugar from earth you know with carbon
and hydrogen and oxygen and so on in it
and it's like that's disgusting i don't
want that you know feed me something
with you know bromine and silicon or
something in it
and that will be interesting so to speak
you know i was
i was amused i i was looking at the uh
imagery from the perseverance
uh rover uh a few days ago and
it's you know you kind of look at these
this sort of sandy
um environment and uh
you um uh you say that looks awfully
like places on earth
but we have this nice neural network
that was trained on basically uh
maybe 100 million tourist photographs
that people have taken
around the world and it was kind of
trained to recognize
where are you when you see this
photograph so i thought let me feed it
the perseverance rover photographs and
see what you get out
and um according to that the
perseverance rover is is probably in
egypt or maybe in saudi arabia
uh it's the same kind of look of
environment so that's some
you know a potential source for some
absolutely bizarre conspiracy theory
um but uh just interesting that the the
martian surface really does look
very much like uh what we see on on
earth
as far as the kind of the geology of
what's going on
um the question of course is whether
whether at some time in the history of
mars
there was the same kind of environment
that might have led to life on earth and
then the question is
if you have that same environment for a
billion years
will you get life or is life on earth
just an incredibly rare coincidence that
will only happen
one in in a trillion trillion trillion
times we don't know the answer to that
uh one thing you can ask about
computational systems is
if you just sort of throw things
together and you just see you know will
this system do computation
one of the discoveries in in my life has
been this thing
called the principle of computational
equivalence which basically says yes it
will
as soon as you have something where the
components aren't sort of obviously
simple
they will be able to assemble themselves
in such a way or they'd be able to be
used
so as to do sophisticated computations
so as to do
what we might consider to be abstract
life-like computations
so it's not a high bar to say that
you've got to be able to do these
sophisticated computations
now the question would be can you get
some specific property like
self-reproduction
how complicated does the initial
configuration of these computational
things have to be
before you see self-reproduction and the
answer we know in some systems is well
yes it's kind of complicated
it's like one in a trillion trillion
cases or something
uh you get self-reproduction i've
actually been looking for
a particular system it's a very simple
system that involves just
uh rewriting strings of characters it's
a system that was first looked at 100
years ago actually
um i was just looking at it recently uh
since it's been 100 years i figure one
should
uh check it out again and i've been
looking for
sort of unexpected behavior in the
system that
involves sort of iterating these strings
and and i found cases
basically so far every case i've looked
at the thing eventually just dies out
but sometimes it takes a really long
time like the record holder so far
is something that takes about 10.7
trillion
steps to die out but eventually
i pretty sure there's going to be one of
the things that doesn't
die out that is sort of has a kind of
spark of life in some sense to it
and is actually going to keep going and
it's going to grow forever
i haven't seen it yet but i'm pretty
sure it's going to exist and that's sort
of like a
a metaphor for the um uh
for the origin of life on earth it's
like most of the time these molecules
don't do anything interesting
but just occasionally they form into
something more exciting and if you keep
going with that
eventually you have a good chance to
form these bigger molecules et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and to form uh as i say it's not a high
bar to do sophisticated computation
it's a higher bar to ask some specific
property like some particular definition
of self-reproduction
okay so there are a number of other
questions here there's a question here
can there be life inside a solid well it
depends what you mean by life as i was
just explaining
one of the things that i think is sort
of interesting about different systems
when we talk about intelligence and life
and so on
time scales can be very different i mean
you know when we say do
plants have sort of uh
thinking like behavior well at some
level
they have some kinds of uh
behavior like that you know the
sunflowers turn towards the sun
you know plants will react to different
things happening but the time scales are
vastly slower
than what we're used to in standard uh
brains with neurons on the
electrochemistry of brains plants have
electrochemistry too but it's a lot
slower
and so that's a case where you can have
things that are sort of uh maybe
lifelike behavior but happening on time
scales vastly slower
than the ones that we're used to and
that could happen i think in solids
in terms of whether for example uh you
know one of the
things about the earth is that life gets
everywhere on earth
you know you find life in the uh you
know where it's very cold where it's
very hot where it's very high pressure
where it's etcetera etcetera etcetera
life is very broadly distributed
and we can see for example with our our
enemy the virus
um you know that's an example of how
these little tiny virus particles you
know
100 um a tenth of a millionth of a meter
size virus particles they get everywhere
actually one of the things that i was
curious to work out recently
is if you take all the virus particles
that have infected everybody
on earth you just collect them together
and you try and
you know put them in your hand for
example how big is the collection
of all the virus particles that have
infected everybody on
around around the earth and the answer
is really small these virus particles
are tiny
and the number that are involved in
infections is large but not
that large and i think you can pretty
much fit
all of the um all the virus particles
that have caused all this trouble over
the last year or so
uh in one's hand so to speak if you just
collected just the virus particles
you just squashed them all together
they'd kind of fit in your hand
which is kind of a a sign of just how
successfully
something that small can get get around
so to speak
but anyway one of the questions is if
you look at the earth and you say
where isn't there life uh of the
chemistry of life that we have
where d where has it not managed to get
well there's a there's a limit to how
high it's managed to get
um it's it's gotten right to the bottom
of the oceans
so it doesn't really have a problem with
pressure in that liquid phase
it's gotten some distance into things
like hydrothermal vents
uh volcanoes i don't think it gets that
deep in volcanoes
and another question is if you drill
down is there life
deep underground and the answer is no um
it goes only to some depth there isn't
so far as we can tell life at least of
any kind that we recognize
sort of terrestrial chemistry um and uh
the um uh what
um uh how how that works
with uh you know we we don't think
there's life sort of deep underground so
that's a
that's a place where life hasn't managed
to get
okay there's a question here from
soap444 will it be possible in the
future to create an atmosphere on a
planetary scale
oh that's an interesting question um
i know uh my friend elon has a
has a long-term hope that you can
terraform mars
um i think his his uh one of his best
schemes involves you know you
you you detonate a bunch of hydrogen
bombs on the north pole of mars
and as i once pointed out to him if
there ever was life on mars
you just destroyed it if you do that um
so you better be sure that there wasn't
anything that
you're not going to be upset that um uh
you know
the archaeological remains of life on
earth are gone forever
it just blew them up but yes that's a i
don't
know whether it would really work but
that's a potential strategy is to get
the kind of uh water ice and um
and so on from the the ice cap
of mars and sort of push it up into the
atmosphere
um and that's a possible strategy again
i don't really know if it works
um i mean i think all of these
strategies that involve sort of majorly
changing the atmosphere of a planet uh
the obvious planet
that we might care about trying that on
is the earth you know if we're worried
about how industrial
industrialization you know puts carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere well
there are lots of chemical processes and
other things
that can remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
whether we have the nerve to try them is
not so clear
i mean there are one that was for a
while popular
is to get the plankton in the oceans to
be uh which which use up carbon dioxide
to just
get more plankton in the oceans and put
for example iron into the southern ocean
to seed the production of plankton there
and that became a big discussion about
uh you know who gets to decide whether
somebody can just go and
take a boat into the southern ocean and
dump a bunch of iron there
and grow a bunch of plankton which will
have
presumably some effect globally on the
earth uh what are what are the rules
about doing that because the
law of the sea which kind of governs
kind of uh
uh what uh what what can happen
uh when you're away from kind of the
territorial waters of different
countries
i didn't really have a clause about
taking dumping a bunch of iron in the
ocean
but i think people uh people got all
upset about that
and then another uh scheme is there's a
there's a mineral called olivine which
uh
happens to be uh rather rather
fanatically happens to be green
but it's a very common mineral and it
certainly said that if you put olivine
onto beaches
and you let it interact with um with sea
water
it will again ingest carbon dioxide and
so on
so these are these are strategies for
kind of changing the atmospheric
content of um uh for the earth
now another good target might be venus
um
and which has a very what is it surface
temperature maybe 350 degrees
centigrade um it's hot enough that uh
there hasn't been a spacecraft that the
spacecraft that land there
typically melt in a small number of
minutes like 15 or something
um and there's a big sort of big
challenge of having a spacecraft there
actually one
kind of interesting issue is if you want
to put a computer on venus
it's really hard to have computers of
the kind that we're used to with silicon
and so on
working at 350 degrees if that's right
tempered uh
centigrade temperature they'll even if
they didn't melt
that still the way that semiconductors
work
just doesn't work at those temperatures
um and so the question is is there any
form of computing
that we sort of know how to set up that
does work and it's rather amusing fact
that sort of the mechanical computers of
the kind that
like charles babbage imagined in the
1840s and things
those mechanical computers with the
right kinds of materials in them
would work on the surface of venus and
so there was
being kind of a project to to try and
figure out can you make a mechanical
computer
that's powerful enough that it's
actually useful that will operate on the
surface of venus
and maybe can you even make an imaging
system a camera-like thing
that uh can work in a in sort of that
very high temperature environment
in a sort of mechanical computer kind of
way um it's a
it's a funny and interesting problem but
in the case of venus
there's again this question of uh is it
possible to terraform venus
is it possible to for example put
microorganisms in the clouds of venus
um to do various kinds of things and
microorganisms have this good feature
that if they're
if they're in a happy environment they
will reproduce themselves
they'll self-reproduce so you only have
to put a small number of them there
and you'll get more and more of them so
to speak if they have the right
nutrients and so on
um as opposed to having to sort of dump
lots and lots of them you know all that
will be needed there uh but i think it
is not yet known
whether it will be possible to do
something like terraform venus
um it's going to be an interesting
decision point of you know
you've got a planet it's been doing what
it's been doing for the last four
billion years
and it's like okay we now have the power
to you know flip the switch
send the spacecraft terraform the planet
uh make it into a a new you know
uh new resort planet or something uh do
we do that
uh interesting question but
um in any case the the um uh when it
comes
to um uh to planets around other stars
it's going to be a really long time
before we get to find out what can
happen
uh with those uh other planets in our
solar system
um the uh you know it it's
by the time you're you're much further
away from the sun
um a lot i think uh to have things
happen on the time scales that we're
interested
in is probably not easy um and it may
not it's probably not easy for mars or
venus either but it's
a little bit more plausible in those
cases
uh okay let me see
a bunch of other questions here
um
let's see
okay there's a question here
um
there's one that's okay i'm going to do
one that i think is pretty easy
famous last words and then i'll i'll do
another one that's a bit more difficult
there's one from sarah
why can electromagnetic waves
travel in space while sound waves cannot
well the the reason for that is
that sound waves are
what what is a sound wave when i talk
what's happening is something is
vibrating in my
uh vocal tract and
it's putting it's it's creating a wave
of pressure
it's making uh it's compressing
expanding compressing expanding
uh maybe a few hundred times a second um
it's compressing and expanding
the air and what happens when you when
you compress and expand the air
at a particular place that compression
expansion
will radiate outwards when you compress
and expand in a particular place
you get this wave of compression or
expansion that will expand outwards
you can you can uh by you know you can
direct it in a particular direction
if you just have something where you
have a little thing compressing and
expanding
the wave will go out spherically in all
directions but you can also sort of
arrange for it to go in a specific
direction
but so what's happening is the the uh
you have all these molecules in the air
and they're all bouncing around
and when you are making a sound
you are making a bunch of those air
molecules be closer together
further apart closer together further
apart maybe a few hundred
times a second and um that's so
the sound wave is carried by the air the
sound wave is created by
the succession of compression and
expansion
of the air and and that's what sound is
it's this sort of uh this this kind of
um periodic compression and expansion
of uh of the air and when you have for
example a stringed instruments let's say
you're you're plucking that string and
the string is vibrating back and forth
and as it vibrates it's producing
compression expansion
of uh of the air and and the the sound
wave is
is is the the sort of transmission of
that compression expansion through the
air
electromagnetic waves like light don't
work that way
people thought they worked that way back
uh in the 1800s
they imagined that light waves would
work a bit like sound waves
and that there will be an ether usually
called in a very victorian kind of
a way the luminiferous ether the light
carrying ether
and people imagine that was how light
would work
uh turns out it isn't how light works
and that was kind of what led to
einstein's theory of relativity in 1905
was an experiment done in 1900 the
so-called michaelson molly experiment
which was an experiment to look for
what's called ether drift
when if if something like sound is
carried by the air
the air if you move relative to the air
the air is always stationary
but you can be moving relative to the
air and so you will
you will sort of encounter the sound in
a different way
because the air is stationary and you're
moving relative to it
in the case of electromagnetism there is
no such effect
the the um uh what happens is uh
the the there's there's no sort of
stationary
ether through which the electromagnetic
wave is moving the electromagnetic wave
is moving in such a way that it um
it doesn't it's it's just electric
fields and magnetic fields
that uh are such that they they're not
carried by anything they're just
things that exist and they have the
feature that
uh for example here's an experiment um
sort of a thought experiment
if you have a flashlight the flashlight
is producing light
the light is is uh is going at the speed
of light
away from your flashlight okay now let's
say you run very very fast with your
flashlight
let's say you run at half the speed of
light with your flashlight
how fast is the light coming out of your
flashlight
relative to for example somebody who's
standing still
you might say if it was that well it
must be one and a half times the speed
of light because
you're moving at half the speed of light
then the light is coming out of the
flashlight
at one times the speed of light so the
sum of those two things is one and a
half times the speed of light but that's
not what's observed
instead what's observed is that it comes
out of the flashlight at exactly the
speed of light
that's the the speed of light is a is a
constant
and you can't make something that goes
faster than the speed of light
and so what einstein realized was that
the way this
is the way that you sort of bring all
this stuff together is yes it's true
that electromagnetic waves always go at
the speed of light
to make that work you have to redefine
the notion of length and time
to coincide with having it be the case
that light has a constant speed
okay well let's fast forward 100 years
120
215 years now uh to our physics project
because we now have a much clearer idea
i think
of what the underlying structure of
space is
and so we can ask these questions like
what is a
what does light look like with respect
to
our underlying structure of space and in
our theory of
physics there is something a little bit
like the old
ether in the sense that space is not
something that just
uh things get placed in space is
actually a thing itself
space consists of this large number of
atoms of space
that are all connected in this
complicated network and that all get
updated and their connections get
changed and so on and the progress of
time
is that progressive sort of
re-rearrangement of the connections
in the structure of space well so
this is something where when you have a
photon a particle of light
um it is actually in our models one of
the things that's kind of a little bit
bizarre it is made of space
everything is made of space what's
happening is
that things like photons are just
particular
kinds of structures that exist in all of
these connections that make up space
if those connections are just sort of in
their ordinary form then they just make
space
but if they have a special structure
let's say they were they were sort of
all tangled up in a knot
then that kind of knotted structure
is sort of a persistent kind of
structure and that's what corresponds to
things like
photons and electrons and so on we don't
yet know precisely how that works
although
every week we learn a little bit more
about it and we're getting close now i
think
um the uh but um
in that kind of setup why is it the case
that there isn't
something like etherdrift in our models
it's a little bit complicated and it has
to do with
the fact that uh so by the way in our
models the
the photon as it moves through space
basically what's happening is
that uh the the the photon corresponds
to the sort of place where space
is a little different where the
connections are a little bit different
than they are other places
and that place where the connections are
a little different as
time progresses that place moves a bit
and that moving a bit is the motion of
the photon
relative to the background of space and
so what ends up happening is you can ask
questions like why is the speed of light
constant and so on
and the answer is a little bit a little
bit
uh brain twisting the answer has to do
with the fact that
when we think about observing light
we're not thinking about it as being
outside the universe
we are part of this whole network of
space everything is made of space
and we're part of that story and so what
you have to think about is what does an
observer
who is themselves part of all these
updates that are happening
how does that observer observe the
things that are happening with the
photon
this is one of the things i figured out
in the 1990s actually
um about these kinds of models is that
the way that the observer observes
what's happening
is such that they will always conclude
that relativity is correct
they will always conclude because in a
sense
they are trying to perceive updates in
the network
but the only updates they can perceive
are ones
that sort of are affected that affect
the updates that happen inside them
it's kind of the only thing they can
perceive is this network of causal
relationships
what causes what in the universe and
it's a slightly complicated story
but basically the fact that one is
looking only at this network of causal
relationships
is what gives one the constancy of the
speed of light and the validity of
relativity and so on
um but uh the answer is oh the original
question was why does sound not
propagate in space
well the answer to that is because
there's no air there's no there's no
compression
and expansion uh to to make waves in
now you can ask a more difficult
question you can ask
well what about uh propagating waves
in the structure of space what about in
this kind of model where we have all
these connections in space and so on
what about a wave with respect to
compression and expansion
in those connections in space actually
in the sort of theory of gravity from
1915 einstein's general theory of
relativity
that has the idea that space can have
curvature in it
so in both of these kinds of models you
can have in both our recent models and
in the original general relativity model
there's this idea that there can be
certain there can be things happening in
space
so the question is are there compression
expansion waves in space
and the answer is yes they're
gravitational waves
and we didn't know for sure they existed
until they were detected about five
years ago
in the ligo experiment um which observed
the very intense uh gravitational waves
the very intensive ripples in space
that were produced by the by the merger
of two black holes
about a third of a way across the
universe um and
in fact the details of how sort of the
compression expansion in space works are
a little bit different
than the details of how that works for a
sound wave its
so-called quadrupole deformation as
opposed to it being sort of
compression expansion you talk and
there's compression expansion right in
front of where
the the sound is going in the case of
gravitational waves
it's kind of squashing up sideways and
up and down
um uh like like a kind of a tidal
deformation of the earth as
as sort of it squashed in on one side
and pulled out on the other so it's a
little bit different the details of how
the waves work
but gravitational waves are the analog
of sound waves in space
in the sense that they are the the
compression expansion in some sense
waves that propagate through space and
they propagate at the speed of light
um so far as we can tell and i think
that's that's going to be true in our
models as well
and actually it's an interesting
question whether there are corrections
to that
it's an interesting question in certain
cases in our models because it's
interesting to see whether
where there are deviations from what you
expect from general relativity
in the case of our models whether you
can tell that what's really going on
is all of the stuff with updating
networks of
connections between atoms of space
versus the kind of usual mathematical
formalism
but anyway that was a long answer the
question of why are there uh why aren't
there sound waves in
in the vacuum of space and so on
uh let's see there was a question here
about
so many questions
um
let's see
um
that's a
oh there's one one just came in here
with child
just mentioned so rj asks could the
physics project predict a phenomenon
that can't be observed by humans
but would be faster than light actually
i i figured that out a couple months ago
in our models kind of interesting
there are ways to go faster than light
in our models
but they're very subtle and we probably
can't implement them
but it's interesting how it works
essentially what happens is that what
does it mean to go faster than light
it means that you can have an effect on
something that's somewhere else in space
and that effect can happen after
less time has gone by than you would
expect based on going at the speed of
light
so just unpack that a bit what matters
is the relationship between where you
can have an effect and
how long it takes to have that effect
and how far away
you're having that effect in space well
the point is that because space is this
giant network and so on
it isn't precisely kind of a uniform
thing where you can just say this is how
far away you are in space
how far away you are in space depends on
in detail whether you follow this path
that path the other path and this
network
and so what can happen is that you can
you can have the sort of effect that's
going out but
when you try to say how far did that go
in space
there are ways to find there are ways to
have that effect
sort of go through kind of a tunnel in
space
that lets it go further than you would
expect just based on the overall
structure of space
so it's a little bit like what happens
you know you can think of these atoms of
space as sort of they're not really
bouncing around
in in the universe they're they're
connected in these complicated networks
which are being updated
but it's a little tiny bit like gas
molecules bouncing around and run
and you can ask the question if i want a
particular gas molecule to go from here
to the other side of the room how long
is that going to take well
your typical gas molecule takes it takes
a while because
the gas molecule is going to hit another
gas molecule a very short distance
hits another gas molecule hits another
one it's another one it does this kind
of random walk to the other side of the
room
and that's a pretty slow process but if
you were able to figure out exactly
where
all the gas molecules in the room were
going to be you could pick
the exact right gas molecule when you're
about to collide with another gas
molecule
you kind of kick yourself a little bit
and say i'm going to collide with a
different one instead
you can kind of navigate your way gas
molecule by gas molecule
and then you can beat by a lot the speed
that you would get
just based on sort of the natural
diffusion of stuff
in the room and it's the same kind of
thing in space
if you could figure out enough what's
happening in all these little
little connections in space if you could
figure that out well enough
you could sort of pick the right pieces
of space to go through
to get to where you want faster than
light can get there
now you might not be able to get a very
big thing through there because you're
kind of hacking space
to be able to make this little tiny
tunnel or to be able to find this little
tiny tunnel that
that instantaneously exists and go
through that tunnel okay let's go find
another tunnel
let's go find another tunnel and so on
and go through the sequence of tunnels
to kind of um uh get further in space
than you would be able to do as a photon
as as a big sort of particle of light
well uh that problem is kind of a
problem both
in terms of being down at the scale
where you can actually
understand individual pieces of space
it's a problem being at that scale it's
a problem perceiving what happens
to those little pieces of space but
because in order to perceive them
you need some sort of sensory device and
that device is going to be very big
compared to those individual sort of
atoms of space because
it too has to be made of those atoms of
space um and there's also the problem
of computing figuring out okay i've got
a trillion trillion trillion trillion
atoms of space and i need to know
what's going to happen with all of these
and i need to know it faster than
it happens in the actual universe well
you're embedded in the universe so it's
really
it's tough to know what's going to
happen in the universe faster than the
universe figures it out
it wouldn't be if it was the case that
the universe was sort of wasting its
time if the universe was doing a
computation
where you could say oh well universe you
just did that very complicated
computation
but i have a way to jump ahead and
figure out the answer
much more efficiently than you you know
silly universe did it
then you might be able to figure out
what was going to happen but we kind of
believe that the evolution of the
universe is computationally irreducible
in the sense that there isn't a way to
kind of jump ahead and see what's going
to happen
okay so i think there was maybe one more
oh there's so many lots of interesting
questions here there's one from jonas
here
about low frequency electromagnetic
waves and giant
uh ultra low frequency electromagnets
could they be sent and detected from
giant coils and so on
uh you know what happens is the um uh
electromagnetic waves which includes
radio waves
are produced by moving electric charges
around
so in a typical antenna like in your
cell phone there's an antenna that goes
along the side of your cell phone
and maybe sometimes another depending on
which frequency band you're using
they're also ones that are sort of a
bigger bigger antennas but
more or less it's the the size of the
antenna is roughly the size of your cell
phone
and um sometimes limits the size of cell
phones that makes sense to make
because of the frequencies of the of the
radiation that they need to produce
but any case the way they produce radio
waves
is by electrons basically being
accelerated back and forth back and
forth back and forth
you know about a billion times a second
um
in inside the cell phone and and when
you
kind of have them go back and forth back
and forth over that kind of distance
you're producing electromagnetic waves
whose wavelength
is roughly the distance that um
that's in the cell phone well
if you have uh much bigger antennas
you can have much lower frequency
electromagnetic waves
you can have electromagnetic waves that
for example are
down at uh for example one hertz you
know one
uh you know so so cell phones might be
at two or five gigahertz
uh let's say five five billion uh um
i was going to say uh five billion sort
of uh
uh peaks of the ultimate wave per second
five billion kind of uh uh changes of
of uh direction of the electromagnetic
wave per second
so um but you can have things if you
have a big enough antenna
you can have like one change per second
why does one care about that well it's
kind of interesting because
waves of that low frequency can for
example go through oceans they can go
through the earth
uh you know waves of higher frequencies
tend to go only through
a kind of free space as you get to
higher frequencies it's more like light
where it's easy to stop light
by just having a piece of solid for
example
um and that's why for example 5g
telephony which tends to use higher
frequencies
is more line of sight it's more like you
have to have a repeater
um that picks up the radio signal and
re-transmits it
because it can only transmit the radio
signal sort of
when it has when it's just when it can
see where it's going so to speak
anything that um is you know stops light
will also stop those radio signals
and a solid object will tend to stop
them but with
uh ultra low frequency uh it can be
it can get to the point where you can
even have it go all the way through the
earth
and so for example if you have a
submarine that's prowling around
under the ocean and you want to
communicate with it
our ordinary radio doesn't go through uh
you know
hundreds of meters or more of seawater
um it um
uh gets stopped by that but ultra low
frequency radio does go through that
and um so you can uh your submarine
can um can get um
uh can can receive radio transmissions
that are sent
from this very low frequency now one of
the issues is that the submarine itself
has to have a very low frequency radio
antenna
and the submarine isn't long enough to
have an antenna
that just stretches the length of the
submarine to be able to detect those
really low frequencies so it tends to be
the case that
submarines trail these wires behind them
that go a couple of kilometers or more
that um uh detect these things i don't
know exactly how it works i'm sure it's
very secret
um but uh the um uh you know you have to
make sure that you don't end up with a
like a wire that floats up to the
surface and you know has a bunch of
seagulls sitting on it or something like
this
uh because that's a dead giveaway for
where your submarine is
um but uh uh the so for example in the
u.s
i believe there's a large antenna in
wisconsin um
that uh is uh an antenna that's used for
communicating with with submarines for
example
it's kind of remarkable that that's
possible but it's a consequence the fact
that those
very low frequency radio waves can can
propagate through for example through
the earth
and and get everywhere right i think
maybe one more
um
let's see it's a question here i thought
um that i had noticed before
i thought would be interesting to
address
um
i'm uh
oh here we go from lewis
uh do you think ai based government and
regulation of the economy will be a
reality
in this century uh all right this is a
very different kind of question
um but let's address it a little bit
so you know one of the interesting
things about sort of the history of of
government and politics and so on is
that
in a sense different things have become
possible as a result of different
technologies
and different kind of states of
development of society
so for example i don't know 500 years
ago or so you know widespread literacy
became common in many places around the
world and that
made possible certain kinds of democracy
that hadn't been possible before because
people could like
yes it's meaningful to make a vote and
so on then then also
sort of communication made it possible
to actually
collect up the votes deliver them
somewhere you know
have it all be sort of integrated in
some way so an obvious question is
as we have a more sort of computational
uh infrastructure for the world
with lots of technology that didn't
exist before you know what becomes
possible now that wasn't possible before
so one of the obvious things that
becomes possible is kind of the uh
the use of sort of of ai of artificial
intelligence
to determine things about what's
happening to determine things in the
world
and one can imagine something where for
example one of the issues would be
who sets the interest rates for central
banks
if uh you know because that's what
determines you know when
uh central banks at least believe with
sort of modern economic theory and it
actually seems to be working
surprisingly well
um that they can have some control over
what happens in the economy
and that they can control things like
inflation you know they want a certain
amount of inflation
so people just don't sit around and and
collect and sort of store money
but they don't want too much inflation
or people are not motivated to do
certain kinds of things so they want to
you know some number of percentage
points
of inflation and the question is can you
control that
by controlling sort of the rate at which
the central bank
of a country will lend money to to other
banks which lend money to people and so
on
and the question then is what's the
optimal way to pick
those um uh um
uh those interest rates and so on and
right now that's done by people sitting
around thinking about it
you know etc etc etc but you know one
certainly wonders
will there come a time when an
artificial intelligence that's getting
all these signals from all different
things and that's monitoring
all these different uh uh kinds of flows
of money and all this kind of thing and
monitoring what all these people are
doing and so on maybe it can make a
better decision maybe it can
make a decision that is that is uh
uh sort of more successful in achieving
some particular objective
for the economy than the uh than the
people doing it
now of course one of the biggest issues
there is what objective do you want to
achieve
and that can be very hard to define and
people might not agree on what that
objective should be
um and so that's that's the issue even
if you could have that absolutely
perfect
amazingly sophisticated ai that's doing
this what do you want it to do
another issue is this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
that you know you set up the rules for
something and then you say what's going
to happen
and the answer is there may be no sort
of way to predict what's going to happen
you kind of just have to try it and see
and that in sort of the practical world
is kind of this
this uh law of unintended consequences
that even if you
you do one thing it has the unintensive
unintended consequence that you didn't
foresee
of something else happening i mean when
you write computer programs
the unintended consequences story is the
story of bugs in computer programs
i thought my program was supposed to do
this but i didn't notice
that in this weird case it will do
something completely different that's
completely wrong
and that's a bug well you can have bugs
when you set up
systems of regulations things that you
try to do
in the world you can end up with these
strange sort of
things that happen in the world that are
an unintended consequence
of something that you set up but i think
one of the things that um is uh
is perhaps um uh perhaps interesting
here
um the uh the question of
of sort of uh can you regulate the
economy
uh using in a more sophisticated way
kind of using sort of modern ai
technology
so a little bit of that has to do with a
little bit about the theory of money and
the theory of value and so on
because in a sense
you know it's sort of surprising that
money works
what do i mean by that you know people
are just hanging around and somebody has
some sheep and somebody else has some
goats
you can say i'm going to swap some sheep
for some goats i'm going to get some
barley in return for this cow etc etc
etc you can have all these different
forms of barter happening but what money
does
is it says there's this single scale of
value that all these different things
you know sheep and lambs and
and goats and cows and and corn and
and uh uh you know
i don't know what um uh education and
this and that and the other
they all can be conflated together and
they all can just be given dollar values
they can be sort of on a on a single
scale you can
uh you know you can use the money to buy
an ice cream
or you can use the money to take a class
um and it's not self-evident that
there can be sort of a a single quantity
that can readily be used as a sort of
medium of exchange for both ice cream
and uh and education so to speak um
but it turns out that there is and it's
sort of a universality property of some
kind
about the way things work that it's
possible to have that sort of scalar
notion of value
now uh you know it's there are many sort
of mysterious features of what that
value actually is i mean
there was a time when people said gold
it really has value you know we're going
to
worst cases this ice cream is worth
this number of uh i don't know micro
ounces of gold or something
um and you know worst case is there's a
true repository value
and it's gold some other societies had
other repositories of value like cowrie
shells or
whatever else but people had some notion
of it's this thing
it's really has this fundamental value
and i think it was one of the
observations i think it was uh i think
marco polo was the one who
noticed this when he traveled to the
orient um
from europe uh discovered that they had
paper money there
and he's like this is like what the
alchemists are doing you know the
alchemists
uh sort of the early versions of
chemistry have been obsessed with the
question of can you turn lead
a very cheap and almost worthless metal
into gold
a very valuable metal could you turn
lead into gold
and i think marco polo referred to paper
money as an alchemy of money
because it seemed like you were getting
value
in this way that didn't have anything
underneath it there was no gold there
was no gold bar
that had sort of true value that you
could pick up and do things with
it was something where the value was
somehow associated with this piece of
paper
and how could that possibly work and
obviously
more is understood about how that could
possibly work and the importance of
governments and things
in the maintenance of value of pieces of
paper and so on
but now of course along come
cryptocurrencies and like bitcoin and
ethereum and so on
and they don't have that same kind of
you know government behind them they
just have a bunch of rules
about how you can do things and in fact
very bizarrely
uh in the case of uh these uh well the
sort of first generation
cryptocurrencies at least
um the the analog of gold the analog of
something that has
hard value turns out to be
a sort of computational work which
actually
is possible it's possible to have sort
of real value through computational work
because of this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility and i
i i have uh i'm
i'm have a high suspicion that the
inventor of bitcoin
was was very aware of my my work in
computational irreducibility
and that that was kind of this uh this
way of sort of
establishing value by just doing
computational work now
in practice that means as as people may
know that there's this bizarre idea of
bitcoin mining
in which you have you know a special
purpose computer
that can do a large number of giga
hashes
a large number of these mathematical
computations per second
um and uh if you you can
uh you can with using a lot of computer
power and electric power to power your
computer and so on
you can get at a tiny rate at this point
you can just
create value from nothing it's like
going and digging gold out of the ground
and spending lots of effort doing that
um but there seems to be a notion of
value that is independent
of any of the sort of base value of of
having something like gold
or computational work done that way it's
some kind of notion of value
that's associated with just the pure
network of transactions
and it's it's an interesting question
whether the
um whether it's necessary that you still
have in the case where you have a more
sophisticated kind of network of
transactions
which you can understand more clearly do
you need to have
only this kind of single scale of money
so for example
if you look at the prices of things in
today's world
it's very common to say well this thing
is ten dollars
okay great but also there are some
things where
the prices are complicated and dynamic
uh for example you know airline tickets
that's a case where
back in the day it used to be there was
pretty much a list price
you paid x number of hundreds of dollars
for this plane ticket etc but
in more recent times uh it became
something where
this very detailed sort of auctioning of
plane tickets based on
the specifics of of how many people want
to go at this time
et cetera et cetera and it's very
dynamic pricing even more so with with
ads on the web
where the dynamic pricing happens in
hundreds of milliseconds
you know when you look at a web page and
those ads are loading in
uh somebody is bidding on those ads
different companies are bidding
to say i want to show that person this
ad i want to show that person this other
ad
and that's all happening uh
electronically in a sort of
computational marketplace
so a question i don't know the answer to
is
instead of a computational view of money
is it the case
that this old idea of things have a
price
and there's just one price might just go
away
and it might be true that sort of almost
everything works by sort of transacting
dynamically between different things to
know
oh well you know that ice cream is going
to cost a little bit less because
we had already opened the freezer to get
this thing out of it and
we already you know chopped up half that
banana and so we're going to it's going
to go to waste if it's not used in the
next
10 minutes or something and uh you know
so the ice cream is going to cost a
little less
and at a point where there are you know
sensors that are kind of sensing
everything that's happening in the world
and at the point where where sort of the
effort of figuring out prices is free
because it's all being done by some ai
it becomes possible to think about doing
other kinds of things
in terms of those sort of economic
transactions i mean
if you were going to work out i'm going
to change the price of the ice cream
because i already opened the freezer you
know
way too difficult for people to figure
that out it's not worth it
um it's it's better to just say it
always costs two dollars or something
it doesn't matter what you know whether
the ice cream was the back of the
freezer and you had to go and fetch it
or
this or that or the other it's always
the same price
um but in a in a world where basically
the people who are buying things have
ais doing the buying for them
and the people who are selling things
have ais deciding on prices for them
it becomes a slightly different
situation and it becomes something where
you can imagine
sort of deviating from this notion of
just the scalar price so to speak just
the single number
that represents price so it's sort of a
a curious view of the future of
of uh an economy to imagine all of these
different sort of dynamic prices
happening in different places
if it worked that way it is deeply based
on ai
because it has to have you know all
those different
decisions have to be made automatically
uh kind of um
for each individual sort of situation
and an agent
um in the in the whole picture now in
the case of
in that situation you say what are the
big levers that for example a government
could use
to like control the inflation rate you
know when all these micro transactions
are happening
and they're all being done with dynamic
pricing and so on like for example
people try and assess uh what
the uh whether there's inflation what
does it mean that there's inflation well
you know
normally it would be well this thing
that usually costs a hundred dollars
is actually now going to cost 120 and
that means the value of a dollar
has gone down because i got the same
bucket of stuff
but i had to pay a hundred and twenty
dollars for it instead of a hundred
dollars for it
how do you assess that kind of inflation
um the uh so what's done in practice
is uh for example is to create this
thing called the consumer price index
and the consumer price index it's a
little tricky to create it because
you have to say what should be in there
are you buying
uh you know orange juice are you buying
uh gasoline for your car are you buying
uh housing are you buying what are you
buying
and you have to have sort of a basket of
things you're buying because different
people will buy different slightly
different things and so
this sort of the cost of living for
different people will be somewhat
different
um and over the course of the last i
don't know 100 years or something
the the the kind of what's the mix that
has been used
to determine these costs of living
indices the consumer price index and so
on has changed somewhat um
but that's uh so now the question is and
even to assess inflation even to measure
inflation
you have to have this kind of consumer
price index you have to say
uh okay things are more expensive in the
sense that
you're spending more dollars to get the
same stuff but what stuff it is
affects whether you come to that
conclusion like for example it could be
the case
that you know real estate in the middle
of a city is getting more expensive
because there's a limited amount of it
in the city is very built up
or it could be that consumer electronics
is getting cheaper because
it's getting cheaper and cheaper to
manufacture something because there's
larger scales
so it's it's it's a complicated thing to
assess that
and in a situation where you have a lot
of sort of independent dynamically
priced
microtransactions happening uh the
question of
what is the actual sort of consumer
price index analog
that will be your complicated question
and if what a government does
is just move the big level and say you
know change the interest rate
that will be a very coarse way to do
things now
what the government could instead do is
say okay we're going to change some
detail of the ai algorithm
and ultimately one of the big things
that governments do
is taxation they levy taxes
and the question you know the the u.s
tax code for example is a very
complicated thing
and you know i notice uh i guess it's
almost tax
filing time and back when that used to
be on paper
you know somebody like me has a very
thick pile of paper for their tax return
and you know that's because the rules
are very complicated and detailed and
you know they
involve uh this and that particular
thing and there's an extra piece of
paper for that and there's a
there's a thing for this and so on and
um
so you know those tax rules have been
tweaked to achieve certain objectives
and people don't necessarily agree on
the objectives and you know as
as the political climate changes the
detailed objectives change
and some detailed different thing is is
changed in the tax code or the
percentage
rate of some taxes increased or
decreased or increased for this
uh size of of of income or whatever else
and so there's a you know one of the
things that governments do have control
over
is how taxes should be levied and one
can imagine a situation
where i mean right now taxes already
have a very complicated algorithm
that determines uh what they are but one
can imagine a situation where that's
even more complicated
and where it's even more dynamic and
where you know when you buy that ice
cream
the sales tax is dynamically computed
based on whether
you know whether it was more or less
expensive to do trash collection in your
city
that week and things like this stuff
that you couldn't imagine doing right
now because
it's way too difficult to set those
prices
but where if everything was done at sort
of the level of ais
it becomes much more possible to imagine
that all those things
are set dynamically and so then you have
this this interesting situation
that you know the tax code becomes this
piece of genuine code
that really is a dynamic running uh
piece of
of computation um and that's a that's a
an interesting situation and one wonders
what would happen in that case because
then
you know it is already true that sort of
a bug in the tax code
can have weird consequences like when i
lived in england there was a
you know some tax write-offs for i think
for race sources
at one time and then everybody was
buying resources which wasn't really
quite the intended consequence
of some detailed thing in the tax laws
or you know people
are like uh i don't know in in england
perhaps there were
there was more uh maybe not more
complexity but more propensity to
to to gain some of these things um
than than perhaps in some other places
but you know all these weird things
people do
um in order to sort of uh you know
drive through these kind of loopholes
created by unintended consequences
of things like the tax code but but it
becomes a much more complicated story
when that's sort of all being run by ais
but then the ultimate question is what
do you tell the ais to do let's say the
ais were actually
making up the tax code for themselves
they still have to have
some kind of constitution or contract
that tells them
okay what were you trying to achieve you
know in this tax scope what did you want
to have happen
and there has to be a description of
that and that itself is kind of a code
that defines the goals for the ais
you know there's a case of this that's
happening right now um that i've been a
tiny bit involved in
which is the case of sort of selecting
things like news content
or search content uh for people on the
internet
and that's all done sort of dynamically
by ai's
and the question is what were the ais
told to do and in a sense the ais
uh and it's uh you know no no fault of
them
uh were told to do things like maximize
ad revenue
you know put up those you know those
news articles
which will cause people to spend as long
as possible on the website
and uh therefore to generate as much
revenue from running ads next to that
content as possible
so it's kind of a a dynamic where the
original thing the ais were told to do
uh on behalf of companies and on behalf
of the shareholders of companies and so
on
was you know maximize the revenue uh
associated with produ producing this
news well so then of course
the ais do a fine job and they the ais
discover
things like those crazy humans the more
outrageous the news story the more
likely they are to click on it
so let's feed them the most outrageous
news stories the more likely the news
story is to agree with what they already
thought was going on
the more likely they are to click on it
let's feed them things they already
thought were going on
let's not feed them kind of the opposite
uh you know point of view or something
about what was going on
so the the result of that is what was
originally just
show more ads becomes sort of the
unintended consequence
of the way to achieve that is to sort of
play on various
foibles of humans various details of
humans
and um uh to do things like show them
this kind of content rather than that
kind of content
and of course there are all kinds of
societal consequences
to the fact that for example different
people get shown very different kinds of
content and believe very different kinds
of things
as a result of that and people are
outraged by this
and lulled into a sort of sense of
security by that and so on and so on and
so on
but that's a consequence of basically
somebody telling the ais
to go off and do something and then the
ai's figured out oh we brilliantly
figured out what to do
it just turns out it has some unintended
consequences and then you can start
saying well
let's add some patches to that let's
tell the ais we really want them to do
this
but we want to sort of also have them do
a little bit of that and then
pretty soon you've got this very
complicated code for the ais
so in a sense the way that the the world
is set up right now
we have systems of laws that govern what
humans do
and they sort of directly in some sense
govern what humans do
and in a sense what we're saying here is
maybe we put in a layer of ais here
and the ais are controlling lots of
kinds of things in the world
but we also need a layer of laws for the
ais because in the end we have to tell
the ais what we want them to do
because there's no you know if you just
say to an ai okay you're in charge run
the earth
what's it supposed to do it could say
i really like uh red
birds i'm going to have you know the
earth taken over by red birds
okay why or
i really think uh you know it should be
the case
uh you know every human should be able
to eat as much ice cream as possible
okay you can make that decision too and
each one of these things you can kind of
optimize the world
to achieve those objectives but somebody
has to
somewhere those objectives have to be be
injected into the system because the ai
on its own is not something that can
generate those objectives those
objectives come from
some sort of outside uh sense of purpose
and so on and that's something that we
as a civilization
have developed uh differently in
different places and for different
people
but that's you know that's sort of a big
piece of what what we've developed as a
society and a civilization
and that's what if we're going to have
the ais take over so to speak that's the
that's what we have to communicate to
them so
anyway that was a a more complicated
question here
um the uh
oh i'm just i'm just seeing one comment
here from michael
um
yeah he's commenting that that uh
basically
the ai
will end up sort of negotiating with
people in the world about what it should
do
and that will make the air very human
the basic point is
you know in the end we have to imprint
human values whatever that means and
there isn't a uniform sense of what
human values
are we have to imprint our
various human values on the ais and
really the problem is and actually i
hadn't thought about it this way
but it's a um at a very mathematical
level
um when you define coordinate systems
for things
you'll end up with patches of
coordinates you'll end up
you won't be able to have a single
coordinate system that sort of fills a
whole
surface because the coordinates don't
agree and so on and i realized that
if you're defining ai purposes for the
world
you have essentially the exact same
problem you can have a region of the
world where this set of purposes
this set of human values great that
works
for this set of people that works for
another set of people that works
but they're all fitting together in the
world
and so in a sense what has to happen is
the same kind of thing that has to
happen
when you set up uh well very technically
things like gauge con conditions in in
um
when you set up coordinate systems in
general activity i'm sorry that's a
that's a an allusion to something rather
rather abstract and complicated but but
basically the point is
that that if you're going to have these
different sort of value systems
coexisting in the world i just realized
that that's
very similar to some questions that come
up in
uh in sort of distributed computing and
in physics
about how you sort of fit together
different kinds of things that are
happening because
you know the problem is if you're in the
world as it is
and you say one set of people want to
drive on the right-hand side of the road
one said people want to drive on the
left-hand side of the road okay
how does that work because normally
you know you have you've just got this
one road and you've got to have a
decision which side of the road are you
going to drive on
of course things get more complicated
when everything is run by ais
because when everything is run by ais
there's no reason why the cars can't
just drive wherever they want
and the ai can sort of use its its
knowledge and computation to
you know just negotiate you know cars
are in radio communication
they're negotiating with each other okay
you know which side are we going which
way are we going to pass
on this road at this time okay it'll be
that way and another time you're kind of
using computation
computation is free and so these cars
can just do this real-time negotiation
just like in the case of prices all
right lots of interesting things to talk
about and
and um uh thanks for what gave me kind
of an interesting idea there
so i appreciate that uh well lots of
interesting questions here
um look forward to uh uh doing this
again
same time next week but for right now i
need to go
i need to go attend to my day job
actually it looks like we're live
streaming
uh the next piece of my day job which is
a
review of visualization functionality in
modern language
but from this stream anyway
bye for now thanks